so really great interface but because
they've narrowed the scope so much of
what they're going to actually try to
accomplish well of course if i was
building a simple calendar interface it
looked pretty hot right now too but if
i'm trying to build one that does
everything
you know it's more complicated which uh
which brings me to another point uh and
it actually i think it brings in a few
subjects at the same time you've got
privacy of information what you're
willing to share with other people and
so on you've got you know um if you look
at the notes calendar you look at
outlook calendar you look at you know
all these different calendars you take
out the logo they pretty much all look
the same you know
a seven-day grid or depending on the
visualization on a day or a week or yeah
pretty much the look is the same
you think
uh in that
grid view
i mean before people had day planners so
it wasn't really a grid view but you
know it was day planners and you had
monday
but then when we went uh
on the pc we start to have the grid view
and it hasn't really evolved yet
do you think that's going to evolve do
you think people are willing to vote and
if so how do you think that will evolve
there's a lot of pc metaphors that are
still stuck in some past experience and
i i often think
it's kind of one of the you know spare
daydreaming things that i i sit there
and think about if we didn't have this
installed base what would we do
differently
i mean you can you can do that about
anything
my favorite one is if we didn't have
stop lights today red yellow green
simple lights on a pole what would in
2010 if you had a bunch of traffic
engineers try to come up with a traffic
control signal for an intersection
would they come up with three little
lights on a post
no
no way
so but that's what we have right that's
what we have in 2010 we're stuck with it
because you're never going to teach the
whole world some different metaphor
right and
you know even in 2010 the metaphor of a
folder within your mail or the icon to
save in most applications still looks
like a floppy disk and i haven't seen a
physical floppy disk in at least you
know 10 years right
so we get stuck in these metaphors of
the past because of the curse of the
installed base and that's no offense to
anybody as an end user but when you've
trained millions of people to do
something teaching them to do it in
different ways is really a challenge so
again as slick as an ipad or a
blackberry or whatever is today in 2010
they've still stuck with the metaphors
that computing industry
invented 10 or 20 years ago
it will take some major inflection
activity to get people comfortable doing
it some other way
and i think activity based may be the
way to do that but we've been talking
about that now what do you mean by
activity like so i'm more focused on
this project and this thing that i want
to work on than some time slot and some
email that somebody sent me and we but
we've been talking about that concept
within our research team for six years
now some of it's in our product today
but we still can't get to a metaphor
that's different it still ties to the
existing tools and systems
it could be that there's a better way
out there and our researchers have some
really good ideas but even when i see
them do new research projects they still
start with a grid in calendaring so i
think that it's going to be some
major inflection event maybe it's around
location services maybe it's around some
cloud thing that we don't know of yet
that you think the mobile can play a
role i think mobile is probably the key
there right because mobile is where the
innovation is happening right now faster
than i can write software i can write i
can see mobile devices with six month
life span coming out with new interfaces
and new capabilities
so
if that's the place where it will happen
you know consumer
adoption happens there as well
and that's the thing driving a lot of
i.t is the end user can go buy their own
mobile device in most companies
right so i can choose to adopt an iphone
i can choose to adopt a blackberry i can
choose to adopt a nokia nobody's
choosing to adopt windows mobile but
anyway sorry
but as an end user if i'm making that
choice i'm making that choice based on
oh android has these really great
features but oh by the way android
doesn't have a calendar that's built
into the operating system yet and even
in froyo 2.2 they have
some sort of vague data glance thing
and personal calendar but they don't
have an enterprise calendar function
building so now it's up to us as a
vendor to go fill that hole right so
every device is doing things different
and now that more of them have an app
store model where a user can put their
own stuff on there users will adopt what
makes sense to them
i don't like the way that twitter looks
so i'll go to flipbook i don't you know
i'm not really excited about
you know the facebook app as it's
installed i'm going to go to some
different ui right
i could use the browser for half these
things but the apps have actually made
it much more interesting or useful
and the new york times publishes a
perfectly good website but they have an
app on there that takes that website and
formats it specifically for the ipad so
i'm using that right
so i think that users will prod it along
but i don't know what the thing is that
they're going to latch onto have you
tried flipboard right yeah music what do
you think about it i think it's great
it's awesome yeah i mean it's the same
information that we're used to seeing
every day is just displayed differently
and people are like no i never knew you
had that information well the thing that
they did that's smart is they go one
level down on the links yeah right
because half those links that you see in
a twitter stream you'd probably never
click on but all of a sudden you're
reading the article or the summary of
the article and go oh that's pretty
interesting so this morning i learned
some guy in switzerland got a speeding
ticket for a million dollars
uh based on driving his mercedes around
at 200 miles an hour somewhere in
switzerland and the fine system in
switzerland is based on
uh the
income of the person who got stopped and
all sorts of things so this guy was six
hundred thousand pounds so about a
million us dollars um speeding ticket
and it was on my twitter stream and it
was on facebook and it was on techcrunch
so all of them came together in
flipboard
that's interesting yes i i really think
that you know there's ways that you know
we're used to our calendar great that's
not gonna that's gonna change yeah
because it's ingrained in everybody and
and
but i do think that there's place for
innovation on visualization and it
depends on what you had like
for example like the ability you talked
about the ability to suggest
stuff to do
you won't have that pop up from max yeah
from a square yeah yeah yeah right it's
got to be a different way of visualizing
what you could be doing during that time
and then how does that link back into
the grid and how do you get out of it or
you know you travel a lot right and and
there's if if i'm in the office the
other grid works for me
but if i'm traveling i would like to see
my day in a totally different format for
example where i want to see my itinerary
this is where you're going to be going
this is
you know and and
these these are the routes you're going
to have to take and this is the time
that you have to estimate so by the way
don't book a meeting drink that or you
can do only a phone call or whatever you
tell your calendar should be intelligent
for you right now we're starting to take
steps in that direction yeah
but it really does all have to come
together and and you know overlays don't
do that yet they're not intelligent
enough to look at each other
so it's still oh well i have that
meeting from one to two and then i need
to drive time and then i need this and a
bio break and how are we going to
schedule those in there yeah yeah so
even though you work like a at ibm which
is you know considered big blue and
you're kind of a forward-facing guy
where you've got well not just for
further but you do stuff that not the
typical large organization people do
like you're on foursquare you're on
twitter uh you uh you have trippit you
mentioned
and then so on and and you've got all
these different sources of data and so
on that that's happening so how do you
see all this aggregating
and and
and is there like a
like where do you see it also aggregate
yeah well i i mean and not because it's
you sitting here but the calendar is
really the aggregation point for most of
that right because
i mean not that foursquare has an
interface to that yet but
they'll figure it out um or whether it's
we move to some other location service
uh you know koala or facebook says
they're going to do one now or whatever
it's going to be but
it's still
event driven in some way shape or form
so i won't say meeting driven that would
be a sort of internal thought but event
driven that
okay today there's a launch of lotus
live so what's going to happen i've got
internal conference call on it i've got
an external conference call on it i want
to be monitoring what the analysts and
press are saying about it how is all
that going to come together and make a
productive day for me and oh by the way
factor into that that my daughter's bus
will arrive home at 4 15 and she needs
to be at the you know friend's house by
five and the baby needs to go down at
seven right so
he you know
time still is at its essence the thing
that drives human behavior
absolutely
sun goes down sun comes off right so it
seems like the calendar is probably the
most logical place to bring together all
the things going on in the world and
again not just saying that for the
campaign
but but you know but that's that is a
vision that i think everybody's kind of
driving towards every one of those other
apps that you mentioned has a
time driven element to it foursquare
wants to know you know two hours ago
here's who where your other friends
checked in or 10 minutes ago somebody
else you don't know checked in in the
same place you're in right so it's
addressing time in two dimensions uh
tripit is completely date driven right
twitter your twitter stream you almost
never go back more than an hour or two
when you sit down and go look at twitter
because anything older than that doesn't
really matter right you know it's
twitter doesn't have a metaphor some of
the apps do but twitter in and of itself
doesn't think of a metaphor that says
here's the latest update from everybody
you follow it's completely timeline
driven
so time is really driving everything
absolutely yeah and um
you know i don't know if you if you read
it or you saw it um i i was in an
interview last week or two weeks ago i
forget and finally the guy still hasn't
put it was a podcast and he still hasn't
posted it but he wrote
a blog post about what he had found
interesting and he was like yeah he
wasn't expecting
my comments on
on how i see
the role of the calendar in the future
because at the end of the day yeah we
built the scheduling service right and
and
and uh to me that was the first step
like actually the first step was to be
able to aggregate a lot of data and so
you've got so that's why we made sure
that we could work with all the major
calendars and we uh actually on monday
we're announcing that we're you know you
can bring in your trip hit you can bring
you know your your different elements
that you've got so you start aggregating
all this whether it's personal whether
it's working
then it was okay well what's the biggest
pain that we're hearing from people is
like it's scheduling right they need to
find a better way to schedule meetings
because they're wasting a shitload of
time and that's used to tell someone
we'll solve your scheduling pin you're
like
please like help me right and so so that
was a
an interesting step but then
you know at the end of the day
we realized as well that
a calendar is kind of the anchor point
for all these different parts right and
and if you look at it you know there's
all this talk about facebook and
your social graph and so on
you know what i'm connected on facebook
to people
that
i went to high school with and seriously
i haven't seen them in 15 20 years right
right how long has been but
it's been a shitload of times and you
know what i i really have no connection
but they're part of my social craft
well when you think about it the
calendar
is the perfect representation of your
real social graph
for a business person they
look because on the you know
not everybody uses a calendar so
um
but if you look at it you know the
normal business professional they're
using their calendar both as you
mentioned for their personal and their
work life
so your calendar knows who are the
people you're actually meeting how much
time you're spending with these people
yeah it knows where you're going what
you're doing uh how much time you're
spending on traveling and so on so your
calendar has so much information and so
by having this aggregation of data and
if you add in the location based
services and so on
you start having this really
data-driven place where now you can
start giving recommendations to people a
bit like your project
it was one of the first time the guy had
thought about it this way it's like dude
like there's a lot more
in
in the calendar
than
what meets the eye today because people
are using this is what i'm doing today
it doesn't do anything else for me
but in reality there's so much data
there and it's structured in what you
need to be doing like when you look at
foursquare
you know it's telling you where the
person is today
but at this moment but it's not really
useful
for the advertisers or for the
the location because maybe the bar next
door
one tells you oh there's a 10 off beer
now but
you don't care about it you're sitting
here it's like you're not you already
ordered your beer you're not gonna go
somewhere else right so it's kind of but
your calendar knows that
like let's say you're you i was coming
to chicago
the first spot even before my wife
that knew where i was going was my
calendar right right right because i had
put it in my calendar and then now that
i said okay uh thursday i'm coming to
meet ed then it's like okay i need a
flight
uh okay this time i won't need a rental
car but then there's other things that
you may need right and so your calendar
is the first spot for it and so there's
just natural synergies that what needs
to get done and it knows your behavior
it knows what your license or your
dislikes and it also knows
um
who you're interacting with and what
their likes and dislikes are yeah so to
me there's a lot of information there
right and so
which i think it's totally in line with
what you're talking about yeah
um
well the the special sub four square
thing is fascinating to me i was talking
to ta mccann last week yeah he was in
town yeah and uh we were talking about
uh we actually initially started to talk
about it in the context of groupon you
know some people grew up on they're
apparently chicago based i don't think
yeah i don't know i don't know them i i
should feel like i should but um
and i probably have six connections to
them i just haven't gone and looked for
it